it's good to see a movie with a cliche
American that's from like cliche
American from the Cold War
now cliche Americans this dude but in
this movie my gut a cliche American
sounds like this and deep down I think
we still do the Man From UNCLE
so the Man From UNCLE is directed by Guy
Ritchie directed snatch a myriad of
other movies including this Sherlock
Holmes movie starring Robert Downey jr.
and now he's come out with a man from
uncle which is a spy movie that's a
throwback to the old Cold War spy movies
it's like James Bond but an Americans
the star now Henry Cavill plays the main
American spy in this movie in fact he's
not really a spy he was a criminal then
the FBI is like will you work for us now
to work off your time because you have a
particular set of skills
so he's mr. charming he goes out there
and gets the job done
then armie hammer plays the Russian
that's right they got a British guy
playing in American and American playing
a Russian army hammer works for the KGB
he's the Russian guys like the big blunt
instrument so it's Henry Cavill and
Armie Hammer they don't really like each
other but these two spies from two
different countries have to work
together and take out the greater evil
it feels like you've heard this before
because you have first of all it's great
to see a throwback to old-school spy
movies even James Bond at this point you
look at Skyfall sound like sky falls a
throwback to the old Bond movies or
anything James Bond is rolled with the
times this is a spy movie that takes it
back to when James Bond was like James
Bond alpha stylistic Guy Ritchie isms
that he chose to incorporate in this
movie really work you're not gonna walk
out of this going henry cavill holy [ __ ]
this is like this has made him a
superstar the guy's Superman at this
point I don't know why you'd say that
after guys Superman but I'm just saying
armie hammer I enjoyed him in the movie
but nothing really floor it's not like
you walk out of here going oh my god saw
something in these two guys I never saw
before
if you liked army hammer before you're
going to like him now if you didn't like
him before you might like them a little
more now we all love Henry Cavill so
keep bringing that dude on I mean I'm
straight but I'm just saying that's what
you're gonna hear about this movie
you're probably gonna hear this movie is
fun then it's fun and the reason is as
much as the movie wants to be a
throwback to the spy movies of old it
still needs to have a plot that really
appeals to a modern audience it's not an
audience in the Cold War watching this
movie an audience in 2015 we've seen
some [ __ ] we're going to be watching
this movie the fact is the plot and a
lot of concepts executed in this movie
they're pretty dated and really two
spies that don't work
altogether but have to work well
together to take out the bad guy with a
bomb yeah that's really it I mean I'm
not saying there's a big curve in this
movies and just not gonna throw you a
curveball you don't see coming is this
weird glaring clash of old meets new
were like it doesn't always work as well
as they want it to work cuz I take me
right here I'm on YouTube I'm reviewing
a movie for a modern audience but no
matter how much that's the case you
can't help but look at my hair and be
like that haircut is two decades behind
it's time I'm just sayin difference is
I'm aware of it I'm gonna get this [ __ ]
fixed today so hey nice knowing you guys
is a simple review because the movie is
pretty simple The Man From UNCLE is a
fun spy romp that harkens back to the
spy stories of old from the Cold War
henry cavill and Armie Hammer they're
fine and functional in this movie they
do work well together but in the end
it's a concept you've seen before in a
story you've seen before executed in a
way you've seen before you do see Guy
Ritchie's fingerprints in this movie and
when you do see them you enjoy the [ __ ]
out of it but since I really did enjoy
this movie as a fun spy ROM I'm gonna
say the Man From UNCLE is a good time no
alcohol required right so the Man From
UNCLE have you seen it what did you
think about it what's your favorite spy
story like of all time we'll go high on
this one whatever it is whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more